mit stolz darf euch präsentieren
mainburger aller alex wie er etwas
glauben jetzt willkommen beim ein video
ich muss echt gerade ein bisschen leise
reden weil wir haben wirklich schon
wieder spät meinen eltern schlafen ich
will doch gar nicht weg und jetzt schon
ich bin nicht oben in meinem zimmer
sondern unten ich weiß nicht ob ich das
grab schon gesagt habe aber ich glaube
nicht auf jeden fall das muss irgendwas
bedeuten so klar ich will meine eltern
auch nicht wecken und deswegen könnte
ich auch unten sein aber ich bin unten
weil ich was krasses vorab heute das ist
wirklich krass und zwar habe ich ja
vielleicht schon eine im ein oder
anderen video gesagt so ich hole mir
abends ruhig weiß es nicht so gesund
aber ich mache dann trotzdem ich hole
mir einfach so was zu essen so weil ich
halt drohen ab und meine angewohnheit
ist halt so ich mag börtlingen sehr
gerne ab und zu mal aber ich mag auch
sehr gerne macdonald so und deswegen
kommen wie ich das manchmal und hole mir
die hälfte davon und die andere hälfte
davon macht keinen sinn ich weiß aber
das mache ich halt
und irgendwie ist mir da durch die idee
auf dieses video gekommen so weil ich
mir dachte du musst einfach mal bürger
miteinander
okay ich mache heute ein mix aus burger
king und mcdonald so an alle die jetzt
wieder ankommen und sagen öl
lebensmittelverschwendung öl du
verschwindest voll viel bla bla bla
schaut erst mal das video ich habe es
wirklich auch so gut durchdachte ob das
sinn macht dieses video zu machen aber
ich bin jetzt auf keinen punkt gestoßen
der dagegen spricht ich meine ich hab
hunger
ich würde jetzt ganz normales bringen
was zu essen holen und dann kann ich
auch ein bisschen und widor ausmachen
bisschen euch unterhalten so ich meine
ich es ist ja im endeffekt dann will ich
eigentlich auch gar nicht weiter drum
rum labern ich würde sagen wir fans
einfach mal los und kreieren ein master
berger aus burger king und mcdonald
bürgern so einen fetten bürger so den
ich dann halt esse ich habe gehalten
auch voll bock doch das will ich auch
mein kriegen ohne video machen nur das
bietet sich halt schon an so und ich
weiß auch dass einige andere youtuber so
was in die richtung auch schon gemacht
haben ich glaube hier irgendwie der
heftigste bürger der welt oder der
größte bürger der welt oder neue
mcdonald's burger so aber ich hab mir
gedacht kombiniert du einfach burger
king und mcdonald und das machen wir
jetzt mal ich hoffe es gefällt euch oder
was soll ich daran gefallen so irgendwie
ich hoffe es schmeckt mir das ist ja die
hauptsache so ja und ich würde sagen
solange ich wirklich alles aufessen kann
gegen den vorwurf gegen irgendwas machen
weil ich habe mir da nichts falsches
gemacht ich habe einfach nur gegessen
okay ich weiß ihr hasst mich schon
wieder weil ich so lange scheiß erzählen
wir fahren jetzt los es geht los und ich
hoffe ihr seid dabei bis gleich im auto
peace ich kann euch mal ausschuss von
meinem neuen song zeigen
der irgendwann bald online kommt also
ist jetzt kein ernstgemeintes an aber
wir können einfach mal rein
b
du denkst du bestücken
leute das ist mein song der kommt
irgendwann bald online ich muss nur noch
ein fettes musikvideo zu drehen das kann
noch ein bisschen dauern aber ihr könnt
euch auf jeden fall drauf freuen
und das ist auch wirklich kein so krass
ernst gemeinter sondern an der sonne
message über mittel aus grünen 12 grad
irgendwie voll vom thema ab wir müssen
auf jeden fall jetzt zu mcdonald und wir
sind gleich da haben wir erst zu merkels
oder burger king
ich hätte gern einen bigmac einzeln und
häppchen mit cheeseburger was da der
unterschied frucht quatsch ist
eigentlich egal ist irgendwas spielt
euch was genau
irgend eins ist nicht so wichtig was was
ist ein was einem frucht quatsch
übrigens techno-event co.com glaube ich
ist ein geiler shop coole sachen am
start danke für die kerb bringt ich habe
auch noch mehr sachen von denen aber ich
habe kein problem
ich hätte gerne peking und crispy
chicken ich trinke jetzt einfach mal so
richtig provokant so rost aus dem
mecklenbecker
2000 jahre später nur ein wunder wir
haben es geschafft das gibt es ja gar
nicht
ich hab so überhaupt jetzt kreieren wir
einfach mal einen heftigen war da sind
wir ja wieder leute jetzt habe ich
gerade doch angst ob ich das wirklich
packe auf jeden fall habe ich
herausgefunden dass ist frucht quatsch
irgendwie so als wäre hätte ich so keine
zähne im mund und können das einfach so
drunter sauge bar so weiter würde ich
sagen wir fangen sie fortan also lange
einen crispy chicken wir haben einen
bigmac wäre ein bequemer mag ich nicht
so gerne kann aber und ein ganz normaler
cheeseburger und pommes und cola
nach viel spaß ihr seid ihr auch so
welche die einfach zu gurken auf sogar
an total eklig finden sollen die muss
ich halt einfach immer runtermachen okay
wir haben jetzt hier einmal vier ganz
normale bürger brötchen mit salaten
sonst was drauf und tier die buletten
mitbürger brötchen und daraus machen wir
jetzt den heftigsten burger und januar
noch com ist das hier ist jetzt einfach
mal unser fundament so darauf hat es
einfach mal dieses brötchen vom
cheeseburger so und jetzt kommt auch
schon hier das schicken
das ganze sieht jetzt schon mal so aus
also schicken und rief alle die jetzt an
heirat von miguel gedacht haben ich
meinte nur das fleisch also okay du bist
wie groß ist denn so dann würde ich
sagen wir machen weiter an die fans
vergessen ich lege auch so ein paar
frauen ist inzwischen machen wir weiter
mit dem cheeseburger dann kommt jetzt
das oberste brötchen vom crispy chicken
alter krass man wie groß ihr tier jetzt
kommen wir zum montag
von big mac ach du scheiße darauf kommt
jetzt das oberste brötchen vom wiking
und das ganze wird abgeschlossen mit dem
obersten brötchen vom big mac und ich
präsentiere euch crew spalter schwede
das ding ist nur der bürger muss jetzt
irgendwie halten deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ihr stellt einfach das messen
hier rein mit stolz darf ich euch
präsentieren mainburger aller alex wie
mit stolz auf euch präsentieren
mein burger der nennt sich alex sie
spezielle okay wenn ich das schaffe dann
war es mit abstand das meiste was ich
hier gegessen hat zu einer mahlzeit
also ich würd sagen wir wollen ja nicht
lange fackeln und fangen einfach mal an
zu essen so gehässig denn am besten
jetzt
ich muss recht zu sagen man kann den
geschmack kann ich so beschreiben
aber ich merke ich nicht weg also schon
heimisch
also ich kann doch aber schon hat man
nicht mal die hälfte
kommt mir jetzt habe ich nur das juckt
nicht geil
leute leute dass es echt so wenig nur
noch aber mich so schlecht als tut mir
echt mega light und morgen die sonne
nicht scheint dann nichts an mir aber
ehrlich okay leute ich ziehen das jetzt
durch das jetzt der letzte bissen
jetzt kann ich es keine kommentare
schreiben das ich lebensmittel nicht
aufessen oder so als wenn ich aber so
sagt wie ich noch nie auf
leute ich würde sagen wir haben jetzt
schon viel nach 214 nach zwölf
angefangen dieses video zu drehen
das sind einfach schon zwei stunden
jetzt märz schon bock gemacht also es
war cool so einfach mal jetzt irgendwie
was zu essen
ich bin satt ich bin so satt wie noch
nie aber da war es auch irgendwie was
cooles unterhaltsames zu machen hat mich
gefreut dass sie das video bis
hingeschaut hat wirklich danke und was
ist jetzt auch noch mal kurz zu sagen
wolle so das passt jetzt vielleicht
gerade nicht so gut weil ich ganz selber
volk viel fleisch gegessen weiß nicht so
vor allem wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
auch mcdonald's oder burger king ist
dann immer so
das musste nicht sein was machst du da
gerade so eigentlich klar das ist jetzt
gerade voll der widerspruch weil ich
gerade voll viel fleisch gegessen habe
so aber weiß ich nicht also ich kann
ganz klar sagen so dass das mein fleisch
essverhalten sag ich mal stark
zurückgegangen ist im vergleich zur
vorletzten jahr oder vor drei jahren so
noch weil ich mir eigentlich so denke so
man muss das ja nicht essen ich weiß
jetzt sich inwiefern das ihr in das
video passt so eigentlich passt es ja
überhaupt nicht aber ja keine aber ihr
könnt ihr euren meine nation die
kommentare schreiben es die fleisch isst
kein fleisch weil ich wirklich auch so
für mich überlege manchmal schmeckt
wirklich und ich glaube ich brauche so
ein zweimal im monat um eine mein körper
braucht es einfach aber ich weiß nicht
was mit mir so passieren würde auf die
schlechter gehen würde wenn ich kein
fleisch mehr essen würde klavier
schneckenberger echt gut deswegen habe
ich das ja auch gerade gemacht so aber
man kann vielleicht auch darauf
verzichten oder ist halt stark
reduzieren so dass es halt vielleicht
was besonderes ist aber ich würde sagen
dass war es erstmal mit dem video ich
hoffe es hat euch ein bisschen
unterhalten wie schon gesagt hätten wir
gern nach oben da lassen und schreibt
kommentare sb fleisch da ist er kein
fleisch und ja das führt mich
interessieren wir sehen uns morgen beim
ein video wollen jetzt weiter wie gesagt
jetzt oder es kommen viele videos ich
verlasse mich schon so weil ich einfach
müde bin ich habe jetzt noch nicht viel
geschlafen wir sehen uns morgen hat rein